[MUSIC PLAYING]
CAMILLE LAMY: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
As Elizabeth said, my
name is Camille Lamy.
I'm very happy to be here
tonight and quite humbled,
to say, to be in front
of all of you like that.
And really, this
is my first time
doing this kind of talk
about my life story.
It even has a fancy
title, so that's nice.
And I have no idea of
how it's going to go,
but, hey, let's get started.
So to tell you a bit
more about myself,
I'm a software engineer
here at Google Paris.
I'm what we call a tech
lead for a project that's
rewriting how web navigations
are handled in Chrome.
So a tech lead at Google manages
the technical orientation
of a project, but not the
people associated to it.
So my project is not very big.
That means I also do a lot of
coding in my day-to-day job
to get the project moving along.
To be frank, I did not want
to be a software engineer when
I was six years old.
I did not teach my self how
to code when I was 7 or 8,
for that matter.
In fact, the very,
very first line
of code I ever wrote
in my life was when
I entered [SPEAKING FRENCH].
So I was 18.
And you know what?
You can become a software
engineer at Google
even if you did not learn how
to code in primary school.
And that's completely fine.
So that's, yeah.
In hindsight, though, I find
that the career of software
engineer really, really
was a good fit for me.
When I was growing
up, I liked all kinds
of creative activities.
So I played a lot with LEGOs.
I drew a lot, badly,
but I liked that.
I practiced ceramics as
an after-school activity
for 11 years.
And on top of liking
to create things,
I really liked computers.
So we got our first computer
at home when I was seven.
And I played a lot
of video games on it.
It was my secret hobby.
Yeah, I say a secret
hobby because, you see,
it didn't actually
seem girly enough
of an occupation for my primary
school and middle school
classmates.
So I would totally
not acknowledge
that I was doing it.
But I was really doing it
a lot, or way too much,
according to my parents.
Well, that's their opinion.
But despite all of that on the
computer playing video games,
I never thought, hey, maybe
I should learn how to code.
And despite both my
parents working in IT
and being trained
programmers themselves,
they never thought, hey, maybe
we could teach her how to code.
No, that did not happen.
In fact, I did my
[SPEAKING FRENCH],
so the middle school
internship, in a company
that was writing ERPs.
So that's software
that run businesses,
if you don't know about it.
But it wasn't really my choice.
It's just that I
could not be bothered
to look for an internship,
so I took the easy way
out of going to my
mother's company.
And the result of that
internship at the time
was I never, ever, ever,
ever want to be a secretary
and I don't want to work in IT.
I only got 50% right.
I mean, really, apart from that
brief foray in the world of IT
when I was 13, the idea of
working in computer science
really never entered my mind.
It's not like I would
say, no, I don't
want to be a computer
software engineer,
it's just I would not
even think about it.
So I wanted to be many things
in my life when I grew up.
I wanted to be an
astronaut at one point.
Terrible idea.
I'm actually afraid of
taking planes, so nope.
Then I wanted to be an
archaeologist in Egypt.
I'm a red head.
I can stand about 15 minutes
in the sun without burning.
So, nope.
I wanted to be a history
professor, a nuclear physicist.
And when, finally, I reached
second year of engineering
school, I thought, hey, computer
science, well, I kind of
like it.
I've got good grades.
Maybe I could try that
as a career, you know?
And at same time,
I thought yeah,
it's been the case
for three years.
You could have asked
yourself the question before.
But, well.
So with that new found
knowledge of my vocation,
I decided to specialize
in computer science
at engineering school.
And then later, I went
to Stanford in the US
to do a master in
computer science.
And after that, I
was hired at Google,
which was completely not
the outcome I had in mind
when I left for
the US, by the way.
Because, up until my first
year of master, what I really,
really wanted to be
was a researcher.
So I had wanted to be a
researcher for a long time
in various fields.
But the research part,
at least, was constant.
And I went to Stanford
with a now ex-boyfriend.
And he had to do his
master in four quarters
and then come back to France.
So I decided I
would do the same,
you know, being the girlfriend.
And, well, so I have found
myself over there thinking,
oh, I need to find myself a PhD
for when I come back to France.
And well it was not really easy.
First, I had to start in
January when normally you
start in September.
And also my
ex-boyfriend had decided
he would do his in Toulouse.
And honestly, I could
not find a PhD subject
in my specialty in Toulouse
that would appeal to me.
And the more I thought
about it, the more I
felt like my heart
wasn't set on doing it,
so I let the deadlines slip by.
And eventually I found
myself in September
knowing that I would be going
back in France in three months.
And I had no idea what I
would be doing with my life.
I realized that I did not want
to stay doing nothing, waiting
for maybe getting another PhD
starting in the next September
and doing nothing
for eight months.
I also realized that I
needed money, honestly.
So I thought, well,
I'm going to get a job.
That's well.
But then there was one thing.
I had no professional
experience at all.
My plan up until then was to
be a researcher in academia.
So I had not thought about
the professional experience.
I was in the US looking
for a job in France.
And I had no idea on
how you look for a job,
like no idea at all.
But I had this friend who had
done an internship at Google
over the summer.
And so he came back and
he was telling me, oh,
Camille, Google, it's so great.
Like they've got
all this free food.
And it's good free food.
And you know you
can wear whatever
you want when you go to work,
like shorts and t-shirts
and flip-flops.
Well. also, they've
got cool projects,
but really, really you
should totally apply.
So, I said, OK, well,
sounds nice, why not.
I looked it up.
I saw that they had an
office here in Paris,
which I didn't know, and
I said, OK, I'll try it.
So I sent my resume.
I got through the
interview process.
And I was hired.
So it turns out to be a
really, really good decision
because now I realize
that I actually
like software development
a lot more than research.
So I'm very happy about that.
I work with great people.
I really enjoy my job.
In fact, I often
tell that it's less
of a job, more of an occupation
that I'm being paid to do.
And on top of that, I met
my partner at a party hosted
by one of my colleagues.
So that's yeah to Google.
But even though I'm very
happy to be where I am,
looking back I have to
realize that the way there
was paved with good decisions
that I made for bad reasons--
yeah, free food is good, but
it's only free food-- and just
luck sometimes.
And just thinking
about that, I found
that it's really helped me
lighten the burden of making
hard decisions.
Because, you know,
so sometimes we
make good decision
but for bad reasons,
or we made very,
very bad decisions
for perfectly good
reason at the time.
And very often, despite
all that we were thinking,
we completely miss very
important decision factors
in our choices.
So when I realized that
even if I put a lot of work,
there was a definite
chance that I would not
get the right decision and
that it was normal, by the way,
I stopped agonizing over
each decision that I had to.
make because
instead of focusing,
OK, I need to find the right,
perfect decision for this,
I would say, OK,
maybe I won't find it.
So, if I mess things
up, what happens?
What does it need
for me to fix that?
The answer I found
most of the time is,
well, there are a few
hassles, but seriously it's
not so much of a big deal.
So when I kept that
in mind, for me
it was just much easier to
say, like this thing that
was occupying all my mind and
I would spend so much time
thinking about it,
and I could just
let it take less
of my mind and be
more at rest, which I
found to be a skill that
was useful during my career.
So, for example, at one point,
I was asked to lead a project.
So that's the project
I'm currently leading.
And I hesitated.
So I took a step
back and thought, OK,
if you mess up, what's
the worst that can happen?
Well you will just
suck at your job.
So two things,
either you improve,
well, or if you don't
improve, then you probably
should hand the
leadership to someone else
and then you go back to
handling everything on your own,
which you were fine and doing.
And, well, everybody's fine.
It's no big deal.
So I could say,
OK, I will try it.
So again you maybe wonder
why I would hesitate
in front of a good
career opportunity,
because I mean normally when
people give you a career
opportunity, and you don't have
to move to another country,
not have to move at all, don't
even have to change a team,
I mean normally,
you should say yes.
But, see, there's this thing
called the imposter syndrome.
So if you don't know about
the imposter syndrome,
I suggest you Google it.
Basically, it's a
problem that a lot
of people in very intellectual
jobs face, especially women.
So basically the
idea is that you
attribute your successes
to external factors,
or you were lucky.
And you attribute your failures
to yourself, oh, you suck.
So you end up thinking that
you are a fraud, an imposter.
And so that if you fail,
people are going to unmask you.
And they will see how
bad you really are.
And in a professional context,
maybe they'll fire you.
And I must say that
getting hired at Google
was very bad for the
imposter syndrome.
So as I said before, I had
no professional experience.
What I had done in my
studies was one internship,
a military internship in
the public relationship
service of the French Navy,
the [SPEAKING FRENCH],
the factory worker internship
in a puppet theater in Russia,
and a research internship
in the public research lab
in France at Inria.
So coming into Google,
I had no idea at all
what I should be expecting.
And then I joined
the team and-- so
they were all men-- they
were more senior than me
and they were more experienced.
I started writing code and all
I got was comments such as,
oh, you can't do that.
Oh no, this is the wrong
thing to use there.
Ah, you're violating the
[INAUDIBLE] this is bad.
By the way, every new
engineer at Google gets that.
That's just plain normal, but
you know, it's your first time,
it feels a bit weird.
And on top of that,
my team at the time
was made with made up of
absolutely die-hard Linux
fanatics.
So they would have these
lunch conversations
about what is the best
Linux library to use
for these super
arcane kind of things
to do like compressing these
song in this weird format
or whatever.
And honestly, I knew nothing
about Linux libraries--
I still don't by the way, so.
So really, I arrived there and
I felt like I knew nothing.
And sometimes I wondered,
hey, why did they
hire me because I knew nothing?
Happy for me, I was
quite competitive
and I like challenges.
So I said, OK,
well you know what?
I'm going to try.
I'm going to try to learn
what I need to do my job.
And hopefully, I learn it fast
enough that they still keep me,
because it looks like
a nice place to work.
So I would like to stay here.
And with leading the
project, it was the same.
I say, OK, it's a challenge.
I'm not sure about it.
But you know, I will try it
and we'll see what happens.
In truth, I'm not really sure,
it was really a challenge.
But I'm very sure that
my mind was making it so.
And it's been my experience
that our mind creates
those perceived
challenges, those barriers,
and very often that
keeps us from accepting
really good opportunities.
So maybe we are
afraid because we
are afraid of
novelty, of change,
of failure, of going
against our own biases.
And acknowledging
that you create
those barriers for
yourself, that's
one good step in
overcoming them so
that you can do all
the cool things that
are presented to you.
For myself, I found that
it's just not enough.
Because even if I
recognize, rationally,
that my mind is
simply freaking out,
it's not enough to
make the fear go away.
I mean it's still there.
So for example, when I was asked
about making this presentation,
what I am thinking is
like, oh, but the people
with 10 years of
experience in this room,
they will think that what
I'm saying is useless to them
because I'm so young.
And then I recognize that if
I had 10 years of experience,
I would be worrying
about the people
with 20 years of
experience thinking
that I'm saying useless stuff.
So at one point, I have to
say, OK, I'm afraid, fine.
But you know what?
I'm still going to try it.
And I found that it become
just easier and easier
when you try it.
And I think that's how you
build self-confidence if you
don't have it from the start.
At first you fake it, and you
say, yeah, sure, I will do it.
It's OK.
I'm scared, but it's fine.
I will do it.
And then maybe you succeed.
And so you'll feel more
confident about yourself.
I mean you succeeded in doing
the big, scary thing that you
set out to do.
So that's pretty cool.
Or maybe you fail.
That's a possibility.
And very often, I think you find
that the failure is not as bad
as you imagined it to be.
And then, afterwards,
you struggle less
to accept the scary
opportunity because you're
less afraid of failure.
So really, really, when you see
that scary, big opportunity,
take it.
First it's going
to be interesting.
It's probably going
to be good for you.
And it will make taking
those in the future easier.
And another thing to
remember-- to make it easier
to stretch yourself,
in my opinion--
is that we, as people,
are not static beings.
We change.
We learn new things.
We grow.
And I think if all of you
look back 10 years ago,
would you have imagined
becoming who you are right now?
I imagine a lot of you did not.
And I know for myself
that I did not.
So I have two sisters, they
are much, much younger than me.
And I have a father who has
this dreadful, dreadful habit
of comparing our school results.
Side note, if you're a
parent, don't do that.
Just don't do it.
It sucks.
OK?
And so one day, one of
my sister comes to me
and say, ah, Camille, you're too
hard to have as a big sister.
If we listen to dad, you're
this like half goddess.
And you've got limitless
understanding of everything.
And I'm like, well,
first he's exaggerating.
I can assure you I'm 100% human.
And there are many things
that I don't understand
and that I suck at.
And second, even you're saying
no, it's too hard, et cetera,
you are comparing
yourself to me right now.
You are not comparing
yourself to me at your age.
And really, me 10
years ago would not
like to be compared
to me right now,
even though I'm the
same person, sort of.
So it's been the
same, at least for me,
in my professional career.
So when I joined
Google, I did not
have the skills to
do the job I do now.
But I learned them
over the time,
like step by step, by taking
bigger and bigger challenges,
and finding what I
needed to overcome them.
So really, again, we
change, we grow, we evolve,
and I think that's
really awesome.
So for me, this has been
one of the thing that
kept me going and saying,
oh, I will try that.
I will try that new
challenge, because I wanted
to see if I could succeed.
I wanted to see if I could
become the kind of person that
does that thing.
And so I'm really looking
forward to what I can do.
And I'm pretty sure
that a lot of you
will grow and will
do amazing thing,
and that there are many,
many, many good things that
are coming for you.
And so, with that, I'm very
happy to be here tonight.
And I wish you all a
very, very good evening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]